good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast and we start with breaking
news this morning the nobel peace prize
laureate and veteran of south africa's
struggle against white minority rule
desmond tutu has died at the age of 90.
the south african president cyril
ramaphosa has said
the passing of archbishop emeritus
desmond tutu is another chapter of
bereavement in our nation's farewell to
a generation of outstanding south
africans who have bequeathed us
and liberated south africa
the nhs top doctor has called on those
who haven't got their third cover jab
yet to urgently book their booster it
comes as experts warn that two jabs
don't provide the protection required
against the omicron variant the nhs
national medical director professor
stephen powers warned that with new
infections at a worryingly high level
those due for a jab shouldn't delay any
further new data suggests a huge uptake
in recent days of first doses from
younger people meanwhile new
restrictions come into force today in
wales scotland and northern ireland to
try to curb those rising case rates from
today a maximum of six people are
allowed to meet in pubs
cinemas and restaurants in wales a total
of 30 people are allowed at indoor
events 50 people allowed at outdoor
events
in scotland all outdoor events are
capped at 500 people while indoor events
are limited to 100 people standing or
200 seated it obviously means hogmanay
events will be cancelled and football
matches will go ahead without fans
the rule of six will also be in place
for hospitality in northern ireland
where indoor standing events are no
longer permitted and socializing is
reduced to three households only in
england however boris johnson is yet to
announce any further restrictions after
a move to plan b earlier this month he's
got his guys sadia chowdhury
christmas weekend spent vaccinating for
dr sidat and his team that is the top
priority so we've had a really good day
we have had almost a thousand people
through the door among those taking up
the offer of a jab around 150
undocumented migrants one of the reasons
for us looking to open on christmas day
was to accommodate people that are
working for 364 days a year i know
that's hard to believe but there are
people out there who don't get a single
day off apart from christmas
we want to make sure that we have the
center that's accessible for them to use
to be vaccinated because it's important
for all of us to be vaccinated daily
covered cases reached over a hundred
thousand for three days in a row but
there are still more than a million
appointments available on the nhs
booking system between now and new
year's day
new data suggests a huge uptake in
recent days of first doses from younger
people in england an 85 percent increase
among those aged 18 to 24 and 71 percent
for those between 25 and 30.
christmas day jabs were however only
available in england with vaccination
centers remaining closed across scotland
northern ireland and wales and they'll
remain closed in wales throughout boxing
day there are however other measures
there to control the outbreak
from today in wales sports events can
only go ahead without fans and from
tomorrow night clubs are closed and
businesses must bring back two meter
social distancing
in scotland attendance will be limited
at large events and in northern ireland
new social distancing measures and a ban
on indoor dancing
yesterday the prime minister and his
family included a video call to nhs
workers as part of their festivities at
home
tomorrow it's back to business the first
opportunity for ministers to consider
whether plan b measures need to change
boris johnson has already indicated he
won't hesitate to act if he has to in
the coming days sadia chowdhury sky news
well let's have a quick look at the
covert situation across europe now
indoor venues including cinemas theaters
and concert halls will have to close
their doors in belgium today as fresh
covert restrictions come into force
there outdoor christmas markets can stay
open but with restrictions on capacity
data shows the omicron variant makes up
30
of new cases in the country
portugal meanwhile where bars and
nightclubs there have officially shut
their doors
people have also been mandated to work
from home until the 9th of january it
comes despite portugal's high
vaccination rate about 86 of its
population is fully vaccinated
and people visiting austria from the uk
will be required to quarantine for 10
days from this weekend unless they've
received three vaccine doses and have
evidence of a recent negative pcr tests
investigations are underway after an
armed man was arrested at windsor castle
just hours before prince charles and
camilla joined the queen for christmas
thames valley police say the 19 year old
who is still in custody didn't enter any
buildings and was found moments after
entering the grounds the security alert
was revealed shortly after the broadcast
of the queen's christmas message
in it her majesty shared a personal
tribute to her late husband prince
philip
saying he had a mischievous inquiring
twinkle as bright at the end as when
they met he's our royal correspondent
brianna milsner from windsor
with the queen in residence security is
always tight but at 8 30 on christmas
morning an intruder was spotted in the
castle grounds
extra officers called in say they
quickly arrested a man it's not clear
exactly where
a 19 year old from southampton
questioned on suspicion of trespass and
possessing an offensive weapon
the police say members of the royal
family were informed but with the
monarch at windsor any security breach
is a concern
this was already a significant christmas
her first without the duke of edinburgh
the queen in her message remembering her
beloved husband his sense of service
intellectual curiosity
and capacity to squeeze fun out of any
situation
were all irrepressible
that mischievous inquiring twinkle
was a sprite at the end as when i first
set eyes on him
but life of course consists of final
partings as well as first meetings
and as much as i and my family miss him
i know he would want us to enjoy
christmas
the tribute came not just in the words
but also other touches
the princesses sapphire and diamond
clasp matched her earrings the queen
wearing the same brooch she wore on her
honeymoon and when they posed again of
their diamond wedding anniversary her
most famous speech about the duke was
also shown
he is someone who doesn't take easily to
compliments
but he has quite simply been my strength
and stay all these years
since his death in april it is the most
personal tribute we've heard from the 95
year old who despite her own recent ill
health has simply wanted to carry on
i'm sure you're meant to be out
at the same chapel where his funeral was
held prince charles and camilla prince
edward and his family arrive for a
christmas morning service
with no sign of any concern about the
earlier security breach as they came to
spend time with the queen who decided to
stay at windsor rather than travel to
sandringham
covid again changing her plans
the queen's festive address is always in
her own words and often seen as a chance
to send important messages to the
country and the commonwealth there is no
doubt that this year it is much more
emotional and heartfelt than we've heard
in the past but again echoes that warmth
that we saw from the family back in
april and shows that prince philip is
still very much missed by his family
and his wife
just six weeks from now
we'll see the start of my platinum
jubilee year
which i hope
will be an opportunity for people
everywhere to enjoy a sense of
togetherness
next year she'll mark another milestone
but without him
her family there to step up and support
a monarch who after 70 years continues
to personally deliver her own christmas
gift to us all
rhiannon mills sky news in windsor
i just want to update you on that very
sad news this morning that archbishop
desmond tutu has died at the age of 90.
you know we've had a statement on behalf
of his family it's issued by dr manpela
rampella who's the acting chairperson of
the archbishop desmond tutu ip trust and
coordinator of the office of the
archbishop it's a very long statement
but it says in the late 1990s he was
diagnosed with prostate cancer
with which he lived for the past 23
years in recent years he was
hospitalized on several occasions to
treat infections associated with his
cancer treatment
ultimately at the age of 90 he died
peacefully at the oasis frail care
center in cape town this morning
courageous gracious and concerned for
the welfare of others to the very end
it does go on but some key paragraphs
jump out south africa and the world has
lost one of its greatest parents and
role models the arch was abnormally
imbued with a sense of pastoral duty to
serve the best interests of his species
the human family and planet to do the
right thing to make people feel part to
advance justice humanist peace and joy
on behalf of the tutu family we thank
all across the country and the world who
upheld arch in their prayers and whose
love and respect for him
fueled his extraordinary body of work on
earth as he often said
leaders take the plaudits on behalf of
others
so that is a statement from
well on behalf of
archbishop desmond tutu's family who
died peacefully at the age of 90
in cape town this morning
the bodies of 16 kurdish migrants who
drowned trying to cross the english
channel in november have been
repatriated to the kurdistan region of
iraq
a warning the following pictures do you
have some flash photography our
relatives waited at abeel airport as the
bodies arrived 27 people died in that
incident it was on the 24th of november
and it was the worst tragedy of its kind
in the english channel
well uk authorities have rescued 67
people who were trying to cross the
channel on christmas day
border force agents took a group of
people to dover in kent in the early
hours of saturday after an incident
involving two small boats french
authorities also intercepted one boat on
the same day it's not known how many
people were on that third boat
while also making news this boxing day
morning two members of the humanitarian
group saved the children are missing
after an attack in myanmar in which the
military is alleged to have killed more
than 30 people witnesses in other
reports claim villagers including women
and children were rounded up
shot and their bodies set on fire in the
eastern village of mosul
hundreds of so-called dangerous dogs
have been killed after being seized by
police this year that's according to new
figures obtained by sky news an
investigation has found more than
fifteen hundred dogs have been destroyed
after being detained under the dangerous
dogs act in the uk since 2019
but the rspca says that many dogs were
being put down under the controversial
law without any concerns about their
behavior
the ministers are being urged to end
trail hunting on public land as boxing
day meets are due to be held across the
uk tomorrow this has to not
traditionally meet on sundays
it's a bank holiday tomorrow so both
labor and the campaign group the league
against cruel sports have criticized the
government for granting licenses for the
hunts citing concerns that the practice
is being used as a cover for illegal fox
hunting
consumers are set to shop from home but
spend more in the post-christmas sales
than in previous years in a reassuring
sign for online retailers a survey
suggests that bargain hunters plan to
spend an average of 247 pounds each in
the end of year sales that's an increase
of 85 pounds on last year but almost
half of those polled believe inflation
may affect how much they buy overall
now it is boxing day which means there
will be living rooms across the country
filled with leftover waste from
christmas day and families unsure which
bits should go in which bins so how can
people make sure that their christmas
waste is being disposed of properly
especially at a time when covid has
already put so much strain on council's
rubbish collection services joining me
now is steve edmonton he's the editor of
letsrecycle.com steve let's recycle tell
us
which bits go in which bin i have this
problem when it's not boxing day
good morning stephanie well i think this
year it really is a boxing day uh
everybody's shopping at home more and of
course so there's more boxes around uh
there may i think the main thing is that
if you can reuse materials for next year
perhaps chop up those christmas cards
reuse wrapping paper do so then you'll
be cutting down on your waste but
obviously everybody is surrounded a lot
of people surrounded by wrapping paper
boxes things you can recycle things you
can't recycle and i think this this year
is a covered year and
local authorities your council would
probably appreciate it if you could hang
on to some of your recycling maybe for a
few days longer before rushing down the
tip or the recycling center there's
always a big surge uh immediately after
christmas
the things you know everything can be
recycled i've got a few props here
kimberly if you'd like me to uh go
through some of it talk us through it
please um this is yeah let's go
well i'm embarrassed to say we do have
we did have some
shiny wrapping paper you can probably
see this and one of the questions one of
the tests for wrapping paper is if you
can scrunch it it can be recycled
as you can see this wrapping paper
is not spongable it just reopens as a
big sheet
so it's made of foil and is so why is
that is it because of what's in it
obviously what is the key thing that
can't be recycled in that well the key
thing is foil it's like bits of metal
really in the foil and when they make
cardboard on huge rollers at cardboard
paper mills the metal foil sticks to the
new product it's a bit like making
scrambled egg and you know when you get
bits of the eggshell in the scrambled
egg it just isn't very nice isn't
workable so if you recycle this foil
paper with cardboard material to make
new cardboard it messes up the new
cardboard process so the message is foil
paper crinkly paper put it in your bin
of course if you've got traditional
wrapping paper and i have some here
and it squashes up into a nice ball
then that's perfect put that in the
paper bin for recycling or take it down
your recycling site and put it in with
cardboard it's good for recycling
i mean i've got a christmas no-no here
i'll uh i'll try and cover up the brand
as best i can
but this is uh an append calendar many
people have had one of those and it says
this is recyclable
but of course the carpet is recyclable
it's made of cardboard
but inside there's foil aluminium foil
and there's a big plastic tray
very difficult for recycling and
if you can take it apart
recycle the cardboard if you can't put
it in the rubbish bin
so uh yes it's a bit of a challenge for
everybody i know but i think the message
is do the best you can and also check on
your local authority website
uh another no kimberley would be
polystyrene
very difficult and uh still too much of
it about some councils now north london
for example
will recycle it but for most people
it's still you know something that you
cannot recycle so
yeah it's white polystyrene it's just is
such a nuisance fortunately there's less
of it about i mean the good stuff is
that the um
all these envelopes cardboard get those
to the recycling sites as much as you
can
and
there's also christmas trees of course
your plastic metal christmas tree can
possibly be recycled in a metal skip at
the local tip uh if it's still got metal
in the in the um twigs and branches and
your christmas tree your local authority
if it's a real live christmas tree can
recycle it very often
right
it sounds like you should be thinking
about recycling before you get to the
point where you're unwrapping the prezis
that actually you should be looking at
what you're buying to wrap prezis in
absolutely yeah
that's exactly right look ahead and buy
even brown paper with reusable ribbon or
string that you can reuse is a great way
of wrapping presents in advance
retailers to give them they do i've done
a good job this year of reducing the
amount of plastic
wrapping paper that's around there's
much less glitter around too you know
you know when you have a packet of
glitter it goes all over your hands and
it's really hard to stuff you have it on
your hands for a week or two it goes
around the house and glitter is another
problem for recycling but the the
retailers have done a brilliant job in
this there's far fewer christmas cards
now with glitter
and less products with glitter but
you're absolutely right think in advance
very hard
sometimes because every materials
products toys still come with lots of
packaging so there is a lot more waste
and
you mentioned steve button there you
mentioned that councils have had well
they will have a hard time because so
many people will obviously go to the
tips now and try to get rid of
everything but in general it's been
really difficult hasn't it covered for
local councils so what sort of
difficulties have they had
they they had in the very beginning they
had a lot of difficulties in that the
local tips or recycling centers had to
close because of fears of spreading the
virus and that caused the backlog since
uh since about the summer last year june
last year they reopened all this [ __ ]
scholarship they reopened and
they've been running fairly smoothly a
lot of them have introduced booking
systems where you have to log online and
go at a particular time that's helped
but of course at the moment with this
omicron virus or omicron variant of the
virus they're finding crews are off sick
and local authorities same parts of
dorset or east london greenwich and some
in the north of the country are
struggling a bit and having enough
drivers and crew
collection staff as well so i think the
message would be that you might miss
some collections um local authorities
are trying to do their best but
like all services public services
they're a little bit hampered by work
short cruise shortages at the moment but
overall the fact that christmas has
fallen on a weekend is actually helpful
to them uh
you know christmas on a saturday doesn't
mess up the services for many councils
as it is happening on a wednesday so a
number of local authorities are actually
running their services as they would
normally would which is a real bonus for
the public who want to get rid of their
recycling and waste so you're a lot of
councils carrying on with the same
collection days of course a lot not a
lot
certainly gets confusing you think oh
god my collection's good it's my
collection's on a tuesday it's now going
to be on a wednesday or is it thursday
it does make it a bit harder so you know
check out when your next collection is
but i think
by the lies the local authorities are
pulling through but it could be some
local
disruption
okay steve thank you so much that's
really interesting thanks a lot have a
lovely boxing day thank you kimberly
great more boxes than foil i hope yes
hope so exactly no foil to be found not
not too much anyway indeed no thanks
steve
now yesterday was officially a white
christmas for parts of the uk the met
office has confirmed the shetland
islands and parts of eastern scotland
saw snowfall from 7am on christmas day
with the met office issuing a yellow
warning that more could be on the way
today video posted to a local weather
page on twitter yesterday already showed
substantial snowfall in aberdeenshire
and just a reminder of our breaking news
this morning the nobel laureate
anti-apartheid activist archbishop
desmond tutu has died at the age of 90.
a statement has been issued on behalf of
the tutu family it says
that in the late 1990s he was diagnosed
with prostate cancer with which he lived
for the past 23 years in recent years he
was hospitalized on several occasions to
treat infections associated with his
cancer treatment and ultimately at the
age of 90 he died peacefully at the
oasis frail care center in cape town
this morning courageous gracious and
concerned for the welfare of others to
the very end that's a statement
on behalf of the tutu family and just to
tell you again desmond tutu south
africa's nobel peace prize winning
activist he was an activist for racial
justice lgbt rights he was also the
retired anglican archbishop of cape town
and he has died this morning in cape
town it was announced by the south
african president cyril ramaphosa he was
an uncompromising
foe of apartheid which of course was
south africa's brutal regime of
oppression against the black majority
and he worked tirelessly
non-violently
for its downfall he was buoyant he was
indeed blunt spoken
um he was a clergyman and he used his
pulpit he was the first black bishop of
johannesburg and later as i said the
archbishop of cape town
so he used his pulpit and frequent
public demonstrations to really
galvanize public opinion against racial
inequality both at home in south africa
and of course globally he was a global
figure archbishop desmond tutu has died
this morning in cape town at the age of
19. let's speak to tabe califang he's
the ceo and founder of brand africa
taber thank you so much for talking to
us just tell us
what the archbishop meant
for south africa
for many of us growing up in apartheid
south africa in the seventies and
females
prior to that he was the ultimate
embodiment of the south african
resistance but more than anything else
he represented the goodness of humanity
he was resilient in his opposition to
apartheid but most importantly he was a
soldier that we needed that apartheid
government couldn't touch because he was
a man of the cloth
we've got a picture um tibet of you
actually meeting the archbishop
i think we can get that up but just tell
us what was he like there you go what
was he like um
as as a person what was it like being in
his presence
he was
there's a few of them there is mandela
there is desmond tutu when you were in
their presence you felt that you were
transcended from the ordinary human
being he was very calm and kind he was
very warm and to to to us he was a
that that is probably the magic of what
what differentiated him from many of the
struggle uh heroes he was not angry he
was a principled so in his presence he
was just a magnanimous human being to be
around her and very warm and very
welcoming and that picture you showed it
was quite late in his uh in his years i
think he was in his 80s already then but
even and he was retired then but even
then uh you will just transform when
you're in his in his presence because
you feel that you're in the company of
somebody greater somebody of uh above
many of us
what has he been doing since he retired
well you've been inside for many many
years now and i think he spent a lot of
time with his beloved wife uh leia and
and he tried to as much as possible to
stay away from the everyday fray of
south africa because
you as you perhaps know very well that
he was not well from uh with cancer so
he needed time to rest this is the man
who had dedicated his life his life's
work his lifetime uh to the struggle he
was out in the streets he was
representing the world but i think what
was so important about him as well is
that uh even even even post his
retirement when something went against
what south africa represented or should
have represented whether it is um having
to criticize a ruling party of which was
a great supporter he would come out even
during his uh retirement to make a
statement against it when something that
is the embodiment of who we are
was being contradicted he would come out
of retirement to ensure that we remember
what we've got here and how we got you
and why we are in the humanitarian
goodness of humanity
it's interesting but just putting
pictures of all the people he's met um
and it it's it's extraordinary isn't it
yes he was a huge figure within south
africa but
the fact that globally he had um
such a following and just so many people
listened when the archbishop spoke
because he was he was one of those few
people who was not uh who would we never
ever one uh uh took advantage of his
position in a negative way but everybody
else felt that by being around him
they were also contributing to a greater
good by supporting him yes he loves
children he loved our
peoples whether he's elaborated or
anybody else everybody wanted to be like
him the same way that
similar and nurse and mandela are magic
of course he was with us much longer
than nelson mandela because even as a
young priest he was always out there so
so his name and his image was already
very global and uh and he never ever
changed i think what's important about
him is that he never wavered he never
changed and the times never changed it
changed him he remained uh
that which
was a thorn in on the side of apartheid
but not only just apart it the side is
it was the thorn on the side of everyone
who contradicted the goodness of
humanity
that's what i was just about to ask
because um once apartheid fell and um
the new south africa was born he was
also a huge critic of corruption wasn't
he
he was uh he would he would stand up
against the ruling party for uh for for
anything against corruption he would
stand up against the ruling party for
when they did
okay
thank you so much um thanks a lot for
talking to us where exactly in south
africa are you actually well right now
i've been lagos i just landed in lagos
he was a pan-african he was a
pan-african so i think it's fitting oh
there you are
thank you so much for talking to us on a
very sad day not only for south africa
but for the world
indeed i appreciate you and he's so rest
in peace he's a good man how he shows
that uh how good humanity can be and how
principled one should be when you're
fighting for a good cause he has fought
a good race
indeed thank you
well a little earlier this hour we spoke
about material waste this christmas but
what about food waste figures suggest
about seven
million
tons of food is binned across the
christmas period in the uk alone and
that's every year so what can we do to
get this number down especially when
people are trying to be more
environmentally conscious
joining us is alison walsh she's the
commercial director of food distribution
charity
fair share alison thank you so much for
talking to us seven million tons over
the christmas period that's
unfathomable
that's actually the annual amount but
that's equivalent to 14 billion meals
and when you think about all the energy
and the effort and the nutrients that
goes into growing that that's so it's a
criminal waste of food and energy isn't
it yeah it why do people throw so much
food away
well i think it's planning it's about
being enthusiastic it's about not
necessarily knowing what's going to
happen on what day so i think people buy
in order to feel secure that they've
they've got enough food in the fridge
but actually the art of all of this is
planning only using what you need
thinking about maybe what you're not
going to use straight away and freezing
it so it's all about the different steps
that we can all take to not waste that
amount of food
so boxing day is all about you know the
ham sandwiches the turkey sandwiches
what do you think people can do to
practically reduce their waste
i think definitely the freezer if you're
not going to use something straight away
think about can you freeze it have you
got vegetables can you turn them into
soup who doesn't love a bubble and
squeak with sprouts
i think also turkey and any leftover
meat can turn into a pie whether you've
got pastry or mashed potato or something
like that so i think it's about looking
at those different elements and thinking
individually what you can do with them
but also giving yourself the benefit of
time and freezing it to use on another
day
is there anywhere you could take your
excess food
that's a it's an interesting question
and it depends at what stage your food
is so for example if you've got a few
bananas that you just think i'm not
going to eat them but you you're not
going to do anything else with them
there are food sharing apps now like
olio where you can go on and say i've
got a few things you know they're
they're not cooked they don't need to be
kept in the fridge and there's somebody
locally who can take them from you and i
think we'll be very grateful fair share
actually works for the food industry on
large scale uh surplus from the food
industry and we redistribute that out to
charities across the uk but locally and
in your street technology will help you
find someone who would really appreciate
that food
okay alison thanks a lot for that
practical advice um alison from fair
share thanks a lot
let's have a look at the papers and with
us to review them the writer bennett
expense and mo lovett who's a writer and
academic hello to you again thanks for
um joining us it's a little later maybe
a bit more bright-eyed well i certainly
am um mo let's start with this this
really sad breaking news this morning
about the archbishop desmond tutu you
lived in south africa you were telling
us
yeah i did i lived there sort of about
15 years after the end of apartheid and
i think one of the many things that
shocked me about the scars of the
apartheid regime and was a lot of young
black people didn't have leaders they
didn't have leaders that they could
relate to because they they'd been
generations of oppression and so people
like desmond tutu and nelson mandela
were really really important and in um
sort of black empowerment i guess but
you know people feeling that they could
uh take their place in south african
society so not only i think did he have
a obviously had a pivotal uh role in in
bringing to end the the brutal um
apartheid regime but also afterwards as
well um in in providing that kind of
inspirational leadership and of course
uh you know after it was
often described as a bloodless
revolution but of course that's not true
there were there were many kind of
repercussions afterwards and
i think desmond tutu and nelson mandela
were very instrumental in making sure
that um any tensions were quelled as
quickly as possible they offered
inspirational uh leadership in that
sense and um you know you already
mentioned he was the first black bishop
of uh johannesburg the first black
bishop of um archbishop of uh cape town
but also he presided over the truth and
reconciliation uh commission um which um
you know no south africans who are very
cynical about that and i know uk people
are very typical about that but actually
looking at it from a kind of longer lens
that that issue of kind of
bringing people together not holding on
to the past not holding on to the scars
of the past but dealing with the scars
and kind of moving on together in a in a
multi-racial society i think was it was
very important so he was a towering
figure not only in bringing to the end
bringing to an end apartheid but also in
kind of the aftermath that followed and
obviously as you said it's very very sad
news
yeah it is isn't it i mean he was 90 he
lived such a full life but
sad a sad time and a time for a
reflection i think not only for south
africa but globally
um let's let's turn our attention to the
to the papers this morning of benedict
tell us about the times they're leading
with the pm apparently
vowing to keep the schools open
yes so this is uh this is going back
isn't it to the coronavirus to omicron
and the threat of restrictions hanging
over us uh we were talking in the first
segment weren't we about uh the uh the
the lead and actually you can see it
there um at the top of the sunday times
starman moves into eight point lead as
partygate takes toll on tories well you
can kind of imagine how given the tories
have taken a real battering in the last
few weeks in the polls having previously
been almost untouchable uh the sort of
the the dread i think that crept over
the nation as talk of restrictions
started creeping back into the narrative
uh you know that's not something that
boris johnson ever the populist ever the
man who wants to be beloved and liked by
everybody uh would want to read now one
of the i think it's fair to say actually
one of the most controversial uh aspects
of previous iterations of lockdown and
restrictions has been the government's
attitude towards education and the
reality is that that's going to have a
very uh long-term knock-on effect on
effectively a generation of people
you know having their learning
interrupted having uh exams sort of uh
done
off the hip so to speak uh and the
problem is for the prime minister for
boris johnson is that people are aware
that in whatever form it takes the virus
is not particularly dangerous to
children who don't have underlying
health conditions people have already
realized now that whether you're fully
vaccinated or unvaccinated the virus
will still spread so the idea of a
school being a vector of
of the illnesses is one that's pretty
tough to swallow given that all aspects
of life are vectors of spreading the
disease if it comes to that uh the long
and short of it is i don't think a lot
of people are very happy about the
interruption to their children's
education and parents are voters and as
we've already seen the voters are not
happy with boris johnson if we were to
disrupt schools for another period of
time be it a fortnight be it a month you
know we're heading into january this is
when
exams start to happen another set of
exams i just think that the the sort of
the the anger that would come from a
large section of the population is
something that hasn't really it's not
really taken hold yet but it must be
said when it comes to children people do
get very irate understandably so and i
think you if you're boris johnson you're
sat there you're looking at the risks of
this um uh iteration of of of the the
virus and you're thinking to yourself
politically is this a hit i can actually
afford to take if it means more exams
being cancelled if it means more
children falling behind at school if it
means more disruption to parents who
will have to go back to work in the new
year i think probably he's looking at
that and saying that that's a fight that
he doesn't want to have
benedict you hit the nail on the head
there is a sense of dread isn't there
when you read about possible new
restrictions about
kids not being able to go back to school
um talk us through what the telegraph
have on their front page mo what is this
dodgy data that they're talking about
yeah well it might be a bit of a
hyperbolic um a headline but um i think
we all remember last weekend sanji javid
talking about the fact that there was a
17-day delay um lag between patients
becoming infected and then requiring
hospitalization
17-day lag it just didn't ring true and
i think like so many people i've been
following all sorts of epidemiologists
and virologists and and listening to uh
podcasts and all that sort of thing and
it is emerged that this um this isn't
correct the the office for national
statistics was suggesting an average
delay of nine or ten days and the
suggestion from the telegraph is that um
sadji javid got this information from dr
jenny harris who's the chief executive
at the uk health uh security agency
formerly public health england and there
is a suggestion that the more cautious
you are the more likely you are to put
restrictions in place so by making this
cautious assessment this 17-day
assessment um
lag
between infections and hospitalization
it's made the case for for restrictions
in the new year all the more stronger
and i think why this is particularly
concerning is not just for party animals
like myself and benedict who are hoping
to celebrate in new year's eve and
not together i have to say we're at
different ends of the country um but you
know i think people like you say um
people are kind of dreading more
kind of restrictions it's not just you
know about parties at new year's eve it
is about schools being able to function
normally it is about the fact that this
has had a devastating impact on lives
and livelihood and delayed cancer
treatments all the rest i think there is
a sense i don't think party gate can be
seen in isolation i think it has to be
seen at a time where people are very
wearying i mean like most people you
know at the beginning of the pandemic
you you accept that there has to be
certain restrictions but now when we see
omicron as the telegraph is reporting is
between 50 and 70
less likely uh to cause um severe
illness then i i i do think the
government will be much more reticent to
impose restrictions and and we need to
be a lot more thorough about this data
and this modeling um that we're using as
the basis for for such a widespread
impact on our lives
i do want to talk about the queen and
her christmas message yesterday it
benedict there's a lot of papers leading
with that
yeah i mean it's it's perhaps
understandable why so many papers would
lead with it uh you know even amid
everything else that's going on because
it was a particularly poignant message
coming in the year of course that her
husband prince philip uh so sadly passed
away and i think it was you know one of
the things that you can say i think
about the monarchy uh certainly in the
queen's later years is how much i think
so many people have come to
identify as perhaps the wrong word but
to sort of empathize with her and how
much they feel that she might empathize
with them and i think you know given the
the the modernizing uh place that the
monarchy holds in the nation i do think
that that's a very key thing it was very
touching because of course it also
touched on uh her faith you know sort of
the traditional aspects it wasn't what
you might call a a modern broadcast in
any sort of sense but it was one that
actually i think spoke to an awful lot
of people you know hundreds of thousands
of people have died and have therefore
lost loved ones over the course of the
last two years uh none more so in a no
more public away than the queen and so i
think yeah it really struck a chord with
a lot of people who have been through
similar situations especially of course
we all remember the images of the queen
being made to sit by herself
uh you know during her husband's funeral
service with the mask lots of people
have experienced uh the sort of the
quite harrowing nature of having to go
to a funeral having to
go through the process of losing a loved
one with all of the covered restrictions
in place um and i think
really you know it has been no more
touching uh a christmas message from her
majesty than the one we saw yesterday so
as i say in no way shape or form is it
surprising that so many papers have
chosen to lead on it because i think so
so many people will have actually found
it very personal yeah we heard didn't we
that the queen had made it her most
personal uh christmas message and i
think a lot of people will have felt it
personally applied to them in some way
yeah absolutely it was very touching
okay mo benedict thanks a lot we'll see
you next hour
and if you're just joining us a reminder
of our breaking news this morning and
that is archbishop desmond tutu has died
at the age of 90 he passed away
peacefully in cape town this morning the
nelson mandela foundation have issued a
statement saying that
the loss of archbishop desmond tutu is
imagine immeasurable he was larger than
life and for so many in south africa and
around the world his life has been a
blessing
his contributions to struggles against
injustice locally and globally are
matched only by the depth of his
thinking about the making of liberty
futures for human societies